and that previous what the [ __ ]
downstairs quick
Oh Oh what's wrong with people
no no Mouse ago Brett - we're back
welcome back to another episode of
beyond two souls we ended with a major
cliffhanger in the last one I'm really
sorry about that but I'm really curious
- cuz I haven't I haven't played since
yesterday either
so let's see what what happens are we
beyond the rift now is that what happens
when we die
it looks like it
good oh [ __ ]
this are we Aiden it's just oh we are
we're like going through our memories
don't tell me what to do then daddy the
phone
if you don't want to do it too
so this is the light towards the end of
the tunnel the entities crumbs or if
they're not my guidance from the depths
of the other side we know
righto mr. Coleman what am i doing
are we are we gonna live what are you
saying
tell me right now before you cheat I'm
gonna live
I'm
in the beginning it seemed like she was
in the rift or something
still questions and no answers why did I
don't know
well it's shipped in a really creepy way
that's what she said well I can move
what is this
don't you dare jump ski scare me
television I had enough of jump-scares
for today thank you very you think he
can deliver babies I'm Way better
that's the mama change your mind huh too
[ __ ] lazy pisses me off why are you
showing me this
did you think it is Jody
better be a good reason for her doing
that
what is this [ __ ] that is a future
notice
[Applause]
goddamn what the hell I feel like my
brain is being [ __ ] right now and it's
just like that's not a good oh god she
shaved her head again oh no oh no we got
caught huh what's with the news article
alright still here okay
she wanted to die huh I guess I haven't
did it allowing what are you breasts ink
[Music]
there's something with left we got to do
are we not like chain or some oh god do
I have to do that aah aah
shouldn't that alert doctors if someone
loses their pulse no it's what I thought
but what do I know about life I really
want to check out this article that's
over here
pardon me get this fancy ass hospital
whoa job Julie guys I guess we've been
here for a while then huh
gosh darn Hey but I wanted to check that
the magazine that that thing that breaks
my head there we go okay they filmed
themselves that's got picked up tonight
they set fire to a building
gasoline on a closed gate away yes then
Hoss well I can't believe it but I'm
glad they got caught you know it always
seems like that those kind of douchebag
gets away movies and [ __ ] like that or
at least real life what do I know
so he looked more proper now it looks
like maybe he cleaned up his act a
little bit after we talked about the
wife or what whatever I don't know let's
go out and say hello to people we have
our own bathroom Wow
the CIA pays huh hot diggety Dame yeah
you don't look too good though Jodi I
don't I'm saying I to be mean back
what
oh oh oh this is where we escape this is
where the beginning is she had that
Herald and I'm so stupid I thought it
was after right I thought I had grew up
from being out in the run with the CIA
now our skilled is wanted for treason
treason have an arrest warrant if that's
what you need okay I'll take you to it
that impeccable Quantic Dream timing
someone's like [ __ ] going on exactly at
the same time all right we got to figure
a way to escape this [ __ ] okay let's
pick up some clothes do you have clothes
no we don't let's go out the window
can we go out the window I didn't I
didn't do something
oh [ __ ] I don't want to get caught come
on man Oh
don't scare my tits uh-oh what come on
that's name they shoulda let us hi where
is she
unders that I heard this is a room she
should be here [ __ ] she went out the
window
no sir then possible we're on the fifth
floor she couldn't go out the windows
all it in that girl cannot get away
she's under the bed I promise you she
did not go out this is a trick right and
we don't even get to see I guess okay
okay fine okay now we're back in real
time right no
ah so confused I'm a brain man all right
oh so this is where the topic that okay
got it got it now I got it sorry about
that little brain freeze happens every
time and now and then so now we're going
back to the beginning huh
aren't really any mysteries left back
here I suppose only when she got left
over to see CIA it won't be for long
just long enough for them to find out
what's going on please don't leave me
here just for a couple of days you'll
see time go by fast Susan we need to go
there's no reason to drag this out shut
the [ __ ] up dick ass father
I've done
I believe the mom is nice
[Music]
I just want to shave his head and feed
it to him in a pie make him eat it piss
in it then okay I'll stop I'm sorry
he just upsets me okay
I know it's hard leaving your home and
your family but here we have a better
chance of understanding what's happening
we can find a way to protect you
nobody can protect me I didn't can daddy
Dafoe will try don't be such a downer
your belongings in that bag over there :
I a right next door if you need anything
or if anything from just call them
hooked up right away
then the actor who does the child is
very very good I have to say really
you're just gonna leave it right like
that
alright find somewhere to change so I
couldn't help but notice she has the
same bag as Hit Girl and kick-ass one
just want to point that out
except this girl is a nice kitty if you
know what I'm saying that sounded weird
that's not what I meant at all change
are God's timing I'm not I think that's
adorable
[Laughter]
okay um what's number two go to bed I
guess what about our bunny I knew it
yeah but say that tomb themself anyway
well let's just go up and get it this is
game play me you like Call of Duty
well you never played as a little girl
getting her bunny by for going to bang
it's a [ __ ]
okay what was it his name again yes
badasses rabbit in the wheel my my first
the stuffed animal was a Mickey Mouse
but I thought it was Donald Duck
so I called him the duck what wait a
minute wait a minute this explains
everything don't creep up on me can we
turn off the lights how do we turn off
the lights
beautiful this
and anger
I'm gonna turn off the light now good
night major
the man says sure
how's that good night night
well it seemed nice at least don't be
afraid we're gonna have a good night's
sleep and nothing is gonna happen
sure
swish science again okay stop
sorry my dog is being really annoying
please can't sleep I didn't I think I
need a story you animate at a little
story for you know since I read while I
said baloo go to [ __ ] to sleep okay now
I feel terrible
what is going on oh okay alright I'm
supposed to tell a story okay well yes I
am what am I supposed to do here
what am i doing I'm making faces oh they
don't like it do they
[Music]
whoa what's this bar how why aren't they
monitoring her what am I supposed to do
I don't know
hop doesn't work through the walls
doesn't work
either way make okay there we go wake
the [ __ ] up you lazy ass look at your
monitors girl you goddamn job
so this happening yeah finally yes let's
go back and save it oh [ __ ] you guys are
busy huh
what are those things
man so many got a man damn sang chisaem
blam
let it go
Rondo D helicopter person three person
[Music]
damn they don't play about how the hell
did that happen
doctor hurry I thought I thought they
were doctor well damn I didn't I'm
scared
you think they'd at least protect her if
they know stuff like this happens
jeez they're worse in her own parents
okay so now we are shortly after the
party if you were us remember in the
beginning I'm an empty tease master yeah
they're pretty easy to kill those I saw
like okay I'm pretty awesome girls in my
class are going and I won't be late I
promise okay you're wasting your breath
Jody it's just not fair you're not like
everyone else and there are rules
different I just want to go out and have
friends and be like other girls my age
you'll never be like them oh yeah get
used to that hey hey daddy Dafoe come
down good night rebellious teenagers did
you bros ever had like a face like that
I was never I was a rebellious but I
never had it like a face would style or
whatever I just had my own style looking
like [ __ ] that's my style looking like a
duck
all right I don't sway don't you dare
[ __ ] sway
wait can she play guitar no way oh nice
nice packs brah kicky
I love space
yeah yeah well that guitar I remember
when you play a guitar in Fahrenheit
it's the most difficult quest ever and
you have to do it to get laid - si I
seriously tied for like 20 minutes for
that [ __ ] right not that I would care
that's be convincing
like I should do this smiley face please
let me out just this once
is he gonna let her huh I'm sorry
princess I can't
it's not my call oh it looks to me like
this place is awesome and [ __ ] parties
but that's is my opinion it seems like
people think like what everyone else is
think it's fun it's fun and you have to
do it right okay that was pretty silly
well women get crazy sometimes and I
guess this is a simulator of it that
that that trash can is really nice that
this mayor and do you have to pee is
that it no then do you have to go oh go
for it I didn't oh that was me Saturday
night and I got no friends playing oh
dude
Aidan period that's exactly the reason
of this no and am I am i doing something
wrong he is that II am I am doing
something wrong
what am I gonna do
are you finding yourself wah wah
stop it maybe why is that my phone yeah
yeah she's gone no I'm not
Oh
how you can see her on the monitor
oh hey would you like to party you are
welcome I'm really sorry Cole I hate
myself for doing this but you understand
right
dr. layke Oh have fun need to go out
tonight
why hmm why do you need to go out well
it's okay I'll just sign here
don't worry we'll have fun now blah um
are we supposed to go though where's the
axe a did we need I didn't there didn't
I was looking for it yes life is life
naina yeah I know
Oh doom it's too late to turn back now
it's [ __ ] creepy do you see him
they're gonna follow us don't do that oh
he's in hiding that's why I mean I
didn't seen him okay that sounded really
gay that's okay okay
I wish she would do a dance or some [ __ ]
like that
well I didn't how about you do it thank
you so they should probably know about
this by now that she can control one and
she can't control two at once she
figured that they would have two guards
at once at least but this is my opinion
why do I know my life
so what's the point of all this like we
get it it was hard for her but uh just
it feels kind of silly I don't even want
to go to the party well Oh Cole Jody hey
like four day trip in it yeah well you
know just fresh air yeah I just I'm
feeling them I'm not I feel like sick we
were just gonna go and get some fresh
air okay um what you want I should call
you firmer no no no no there's there's
there's no need I'm you know Cole's
looking after me right cool
hey uh well you know just tellin ya he'd
speak he lost his voice
a virus ah that's more than that's more
than I've gotten out of them all all day
long it's not contagious buddy you
should be home in bed if you ask me
safer for all of us all right see you go
on that whoa did you see her face
that's [ __ ] creepy man Oh weird at
least we don't have to look for Cole's
car
why does Cole know where it is
Oh everywhere I do not hang around here
too long okay am i driving or cold I
guess I'm driving yet Cole's got the
keys he's the man with the keys and the
she's hair yeah God a day now get in the
car and start it out and if you wanted
to you could just said oh no but you
ratted twice the place and no showed up
and took the life out RAM will boil it
takes a gator started
does Aiden know how to drive I wouldn't
trust him probably driven a car before
why not really out of sight so except
the car and get out of sight
now we're gonna go into trunk okay all
right let's go let's go
[Music]
you guys ever snuck out of your parents
like that yeah I think anyone has how
are you escaping from the CIA's just to
get over to a party okay that brought to
me a lot thanks for that Quantic Dream
okay continious then is again what is he
doing he's gonna open for her okay
gotcha gotcha we did a myth party it's
bad
you'll forgive me right never I'll be
back soon don't worry I'll be fine
okay I didn't take him into the forest
make sure he's safe and then why the
forest huh what happens in the forest
may I have this looks like a good spot
for a forest trip
I'm sure he'll love it yes the forest
the forest is a good spot I'm sure he'll
be safe unless someone eats him oh this
is the place the girls must be inside
already huh
then we shall go to Empire you boys
ready to party you boys in a party mood
yeah let's show all my dance move we're
gonna get in trouble
what are you wrestling look at that emo
chick looker well is it will wait no we
don't we get out of here hey girl can I
buy you a drink no thing oh [ __ ]
what does it say in the background I was
like hey Heineken or something Oh mess
oh my bad
look at that girl like the music in this
game so while we're not doing anything I
always argue with my GI if lemonade has
to be with lemons because we call it
soft in Sweden and it could be made out
of berries or anything there's still
lemonade sign she gonna play cold with
himself how about you guys [ __ ] off
[Applause]
rather just playing my own it's okay
six-two
what are you bursting don't they seem
kind of shady I don't know them and
they're way too old for me anyway so
it's like well then again it's not like
anything bad can happen like
[Music]
yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing here
alone some say
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
yeah
your parents know you're here in vain
are we playing pool or 20 questions what
happens in the music oh what the [ __ ] no
you won't do baby I know repulsive [ __ ]
the hell oh no what the [ __ ] oh you guys
[ __ ] with the wrong girl where are you
creep show yourself
oh sure we're gonna kill someone I want
to kill someone can I come in please
poor girl
there we go
in the face kinda owe money Thanks oh
nice
what have you supposed to do I don't
know how much we can do this can figure
let's smash their life shut the [ __ ] up
right
and you are you know you can try no no I
don't want to kill him
I'm sorry will control him that's what
we do
Oh
[Music]
what are you doing Earl Earl Oh Daisy it
was me
BAM shall say I'm Sam and it slam with
the Bama Ram banger Chang later
alligator skater Oh Oh Shh Oh Shh
[Music]
it's okay
yeah that is some okay well that was
house that was pretty interesting
actually all right I'm gonna have to end
this episode here was enjoyed never like
if you did helps me out a lot
I hope you appreciate the extra long
episodes I think it's more fun for you
to watch as well let me like envisioned
you are watching his sky remembered the
day I'll see you in the next one it's a
awesome
[Music]